what does the lava feel like lava
lava real actual lava it was real actual
lava
pretty warm it was pretty warm and a
little gooey yeah
a lot was gooeyer than you'd expect i
feel like this is going to be like you
know when you watch nickelodeon when
you're younger and you're like i just
want to know what the slime feels like
and the slime tastes like that's how i
am with this lava now
it's a great mystery everybody wants to
know hello
vertsy triplets there's only one rule to
this game
don't fall in because the floor
i am talking to two ghosts and one
survivor from the floor is lava
um what can you guys uh just identify
yourselves real quick so i can
we know who who is who yeah i'm sean
i'm alex i'm mitchell versus and
together we're the bursi triplets
oh my gosh so they pronounced your guy's
name wrong on the show
they butchered our last name which was
annoying but guys i've been practicing i
was like i'm gonna get it right
yeah they added a d somehow i don't know
how it got to bertsy
yeah it right it rhymes with jersey so
versey jersey not
curtsy yeah yeah messed up pretty bad on
that one
but contrary to popular belief you guys
are not from jersey
nobody thinks that everybody thinks that
that's not true
we're actually la boys which is no one
ever guessed that
which is even more hateable yeah
now the forest lava is the number one
show on netflix and people are just
captivated by it i mean what has it been
like for you guys
i think we've all been surprised by the
response we've gotten i
the show has done so much better than we
expected yeah
everybody's been super supportive hates
us which is you know about the same
thing as supportive love or hate and
i i can't believe how well it's done
yeah because it's a kid i mean it's a
kids show and usually
you know the top of netflix for it's
been number one for literally ten
straight days
and i don't want to say it's cause we're
in the pilot episode but that is just
a fact but um i will also say that i
think a lot of people get like very
nostalgic vibes i think a lot of people
think of like legends of the hidden
temple
it kind of brings them back to their
childhood they think they can do it
so i think that's another reason why
it's been so popular at least it's much
harder than it looks
yeah it's much harder to work well the
eps did this interview
where they were like everyone who kind
of tried out didn't really know what the
show was going to be we didn't have the
name of the show yet so what did you
guys think you were getting into verse
like when you show up to the
burbank ikea
i honestly didn't we knew it was gonna
be like a kid show we knew it was gonna
be like an obstacle course
and we're like all right we're fit we
got we got guns you know what i'm saying
this should be no problem so we talked a
whole bunch of trash too
yeah uh and we got worked pretty bad
yeah
i think the the production value was so
much better than we were expecting yeah
the courses the the cat like everything
that was put together was incredible
uh we were not expecting it to look so
amazing
so spoiler alert you guys do not succeed
uh in your course so at what point do
you guys realize like we're
we're in trouble here uh we honestly
thought that we were winning
we thought that we were like oh if we
couldn't do it then none of the other
teams
that's how that's how dumb and arrogant
we were about it but uh no apparently we
lost to a mom
yeah so two kids so i mean
i think we realized it once mitchell's
uh tiny little leg
couldn't reach the step that's when i
was like oh we're squirting
oh man that moment i mean like
mitchell you were all the way at the end
and then just like a tragic death
like what went wrong there uh you know i
i thought that net that i was holding on
to would give a little more swing
but when i swung forward i'm like oh
i'll leave with my you know i thought my
body would go forward but it was just
face first
and i just i get it i can tell you
exactly what happened our five foot
six dad and our five foot mom had three
triplets that are five four and we just
five five five five he's five four five
and on tinder we're five eight so
mom and dad make me so short what people
didn't see was he was doing
pull-ups for about a minute and a half
and then
hanging for another three minutes before
he finally ate it i might have burned
out yeah
just go don't show off oh sorry that
sounds all right
sean you fell off the pyramid which is
the same period we see talia do her big
sacrifice
um what like how difficult was that
pyramid because that thing looked
impossible
like no one could get off that thing it
it had
no give like the signs were the
the ledges were like maybe a half inch
but every time you stepped on it it
would just it was kind of like foam it
would just push in
so there's really nothing you could step
on uh i'd like to say i sacrificed
myself too
just like talia we just happened to not
win
for something you just kind of fell off
ungracefully slitted yours was
well what happened was i i stopped
holding on to the top because i was
shimming my way down and i was yelling
at alex because he was yelling at me
and then i got distracted looking at him
and i just slid in
so he also turned into a meme he went
viral with this
one the one thing he said like when took
off on all the uh
you know all the apps why did you stop
working out i was sad
that was the um most iconic line of
dialogue in 2020
thank you so many people related to it
that is the 2020
mood yeah yeah still looks sad so that's
kind of
we don't know yeah we need an update are
you still sad
why were you sad uh i was sad because i
have to deal with them all the time
i live with them i work with them i
perform with them i'm pretty much
married to them so you can tell me
if you had to deal with two of your ex
boyfriends all the time you tell
like you'd be sad too sounds like a
dream true for most ladies
so when you get to the course like do
you know that everything
in the room is usable because it was
almost like an escape room meets like an
obstacle course
yeah i mean we're aware that like if
there's an object the whole
point is like don't fall in the lava
everything else is kind of like a
free-for-all
so yeah like we're just like okay what
can we use and there was only a couple
things that you could use
so we made the best of it one of you got
lava in your mouth what was that like
yeah that was me um it was hot it was
it was toasty i was not expecting that i
think i immediately spit it out because
i
they just yeah in my face my favorite
thing about this show is just
the way that people react when people
fall into the lava like they are
literally dying for real
it's like losing ten thousand dollars
you would spend ten thousand dollars
being thrown out the window
so well i will say it was very hard not
to laugh when mitchell face planted yeah
it was so hard not to laugh
when when shawn slid off the pyramid on
the last one they had to do the backside
of me
because i was laughing because while he
was mid-fall he looked at me in the eyes
and i could tell he was trying to be
like this is your fault and i'm like no
that's
that's your fault and then then i just
couldn't stop laughing
yeah tell me about your your response on
social media
how graphic can we be go you know what
just go
for it we'll we'll let me do the editing
oh boy you know when you get one of
these like when you get like your first
big exposure you're always like oh so
many girls are gonna hit me up
it's never like that it's like going to
the gym and you try and get in really
good shape and you're like oh look at
all these muscles
and none of the girls care it's always
guys that come up and talk to you
like nice latch dude that's exactly what
happened one of my favorite tweets
it's a little cleaner is uh watching the
floor is lava and i have some comments
the main one being i want the vergey
triplets to wreck me
over and over and over and over and over
again
yeah please wreck me verses i mean i've
loved watching you guys just kind of
respond to pretty much
everyone on twitter like are you just
searching triplets and just
yeah we love we love to troll people
especially
especially people that don't like it
because it's not that hard like triplets
is a very unique thing so it's easy to
search
all right we know someone's going to
talk smack and then we'd like to find it
and then we just make it even
way more annoying than we already were
or we you know
i think some people also caught onto it
because there was one guy that's like i
bet the versi triplets are so shallow
that they'll actually look up this
and see if we're talking about them and
then i retweeted saying you're
absolutely right
like you guys probably got like a couple
of weird tweets but now people are just
doing it to see if you guys will respond
yeah i think so and again what else are
we going to do we have all this time
reach out to us we'll respond
i would say i was very different right
there i i'm sad i'm a
sad human being okay so who's who's
single
of the triplets all three of us are
single we are
yeah we're all single ready to mingle uh
not touch the pringle uh because a lot
of good that makes sense no no yeah
that's not me
edit
[Laughter]
so you guys did you guys live together
yep yeah we we
we we're all single we all live together
we work together we do
we perform stand up together we're
always around each other
like i said we're pretty much married we
got hair transplants together it was
very adorable
best way to tell us apart is probably by
the hairline so this is the thing in the
show you guys said we could tell you
apart by your hairlines now these are
all going to change we're all confused
now so how do we tell you apart
you'll just have to keep updated with
the social media and see how our
our hair journey progresses you can
follow the
usually usually personality i get more i
usually get more of the
douchey vibe shawn's more of that you
would probably like sean because you're
you got like star wars in the background
so you're kind of nerdy so that's more
sean's point
sounds more of a dead bod sort of dude
kind of guy i exude comfort
and then uh mitch is more of a beta you
know if you're looking to be more of an
alpha woman i would not say that mitch
is
definitely kind of did i eat did i lose
to a mom on four's lobby yes but i would
not
classify myself as beta
well you guys are you guys are getting
the daddy uh moniker now so
yeah again very proud of that we got we
got daddy uh
zaddy was another one which i hadn't
heard that's yeah
yeah it's a more flattering daddy and
then someone called us the
versati triplets which i like a lot it's
that's good that's good so do you think
if they do a season two which i assume
they will because it's so popular
do you think like would you guys want to
go back and try to redeem yourselves
oh absolutely we still think we should
have won the show
we still think we're the best
competitors even though we had zero
points yeah
we tell that to talia yeah yeah we're
down to redeem ourselves
in our defense talia did nothing she
didn't get any points she got as many
points as we did
and i technically didn't fall off so i
still had hope to get points
that's why i see it this is how in
denial we are about losing
so if i was gonna be on the show next
season because i'd sure like to be
um what advice would you have for me
uh grow longer limbs would be my first
bit of advice
where where uh ankle weights uh and hang
your
legs over the bed when you sleep so they
just pull it down so you get longer legs
i would heavily recommend parkour that
is definitely the best way to learn how
to
beat the floors lava is a hardcore
regiment
and basketball shoes you wouldn't think
of it
we went with like crappy old gym shoes
if you had some shoes with some nice
grip to catch that lava in there
you're gonna be unstoppable that's the
main bit of advice that and don't use
your face to break your fall
okay like fall forward not your face
you